hello I'm Eleanor Bosch welcome to my
office what I want to do today is
introduce you to the GigaPan epic pro
units we'll talk a little bit about the
hardware and about some of the
considerations of using full-scale DSLR
cameras with big zoom lenses on this
hardware so first of all here's a great
example of the hardware it has a pan
motor on the bottom it's a stepper motor
it's a quite strong so it can handle
quite a bit of load and then it has two
steppers on the sides which it uses for
tilts it's very hard to move this by
hand you have to push and be patient and
then it has some adjustments for the
nodal point so that you can get your
pack camera to not have parallax one is
the four aft adjustment here and the
other is there's a height adjustment
here the whole unit can go up and down
also the pro unit demands an electronic
shutter so in fact there's a set of
cables that come with it with different
types of connectors for all the various
cameras on the market the DSLRs on the
market so you can trigger the camera
appropriately some people have also used
it by having it move the panorama
between positions the camera between
positions and they press the shutter
button manually on their robot that of
course works too let me also tell you
about the battery the battery is a
custom battery unit here on the side and
it's a nickel metal hydride battery pack
it's 4300 milli amp hours and it lasts a
large number of of GigaPan typically you
can use it for anywhere from 5 to 15
complete you can pan panoramas I'll put
the battery pack back and explain one
other thing about the battery that's
important which is the battery is
charged in the unit there's a charger
dock right here and what's nice about
that is you could actually plug this
into the AC adapter that comes with the
unit and you can charge the battery
while you're taking Giga pens and so you
can have the charger plugged in you can
use the system and it's like a laptop in
the sense that it's charging when it can
and it's using power webcam so that
covers the fundamentals of the hardware
let's run you through the menu screens
and talk about what they do
you turn it on just by holding in the
power button and once we've done that we
go into the main menu new panorama and
360 panorama or the settings are gonna
use to take a panorama new panorama will
ask you to set the top left and bottom
right corners of the panorama 360
panorama ask you to set just the top and
bottom edge and it takes it all the way
around the other option that I want to
show you right away is move camera move
camera is quite useful because this
thing is so heavy once you've got the
DSLR on here and you're trying to adjust
exposure and go to different parts of
the scene move camera is great because
once you're in that mode you can move
around you can look at the scene you can
figure out what the exposure reads in
different positions how much the shallow
depth of field you have matters or
doesn't matter and such and then you can
cancel out of that whenever you like
so move camera is a very very useful way
to just move your camera around and get
a feel for the scene now there's a few
other menus so I'm going to go back up
to the top we talked about a new
panorama and 360 panorama let's just run
through options so let's dive into
options and just talk briefly about the
various options in here time for pic
this is essentially the amount of time
the camera the robot is going to wait
between pictures that it takes this is
set by default to about 3 seconds in
this case 2.5 seconds out of the factory
and the reason to make this long is
because for example the exposure is
gonna be quite long on the camera and
you want plenty of time to deal with the
exposure and deal with writing to the SD
card before you take the next picture so
here you can adjust how long the robot
takes between pictures start delay is
also very useful the idea here is do you
want to trigger the beginning of the
panorama with an external trigger
did you plug in on the bottom of the
unit so that the panoramas begin doesn't
begin to be acquired until you want it
to or do you want to introduce a delay
like let's say five minutes after you
say go you want it to begin taking the
panorama so that you can run into the
scene or so that an event can occur so
that's a start delay multiple shutter is
where you can specify how many times you
want the trigger to go off in each
position of the panorama picture order
allows you to specify whether you want
column or row ordering of the pictures
in the panorama left to right right to
left top to bottom or bottom to top
battery status is nice because it shows
you the voltage of the system seven
point eight volts is great anything
about seven volts I consider quite good
I'm gonna cancel out of that and in
factory reset of course does exactly
what it looks like and we'll leave
expert options as homework for the
student at home so those are options
panorama memory allows you to call up
the last panorama this is very useful if
you want to do
time-lapse like work take the same
panorama over and over again or if you
take it panorama and then something
really neat happens a lion comes and
sits down in the middle of the bush and
what you want to do is go right back to
that position in the panorama and shoot
that particular picture again and
integrate that into the panorama that
you're about to stitch so panorama
memory makes it easy to do that camera
setup is very important what you do with
camera setup is you set the field of
view of your system now that field of
view of course determines the number of
degrees that the GigaPan Pro should move
between pictures so there's two things
that you're set here one thing that you
set is the actual native field of view
that you your camera has at the zoom
level that you've chosen to use and so
you have your camera on here and you set
it by physically moving the camera and
I'll show you how to do that once we
mount the camera the other thing that
you set in camera setup is you can set
the percentage of overlap that you want
so do you want thirty percent overlap
between pictures or forty percent or
twenty percent okay that is a
description really briefly of some of
the main menus on the Cape an epic pro
now let's pull this aside and talk about
a DSLR and some of the considerations
when you're going to be doing some
picture taking now DSLRs are fantastic
for Giga panning because the image
sensors are large you're going to get
very high quality images even in
relatively low light conditions and what
I want to do is talk about the lens a
little bit and then talk about the
camera I'm just gonna give you an as an
example this is a Canon 5d Mark 2 and it
has a 70 to 200 millimeter lens on it so
let's start with the lens there are some
issues that you'll have questions about
one of the biggest questions is all I
was about autofocus versus manual focus
so should I use autofocus should I use
manual focus well the answer is
depends in a situation where you can
lock the focus with manual focus and
really nail what you want that's
fantastic and there's one important
reason for that when you trigger these
cameras to take a picture if you put
them in auto focus mode and they can't
get any contrast and therefore can't
focus they'll often not take a picture
so you're gonna miss a shot and that's
really bad so what some of our members
will do is they'll put the camera in
manual focus for the sky and they'll put
it in say row mode and for the sky
they'll nail it at infinity and take the
pictures and then when they get to the
tree line or to the grass or to the
crowd they'll go to autofocus so that
each picture gets to an optimum focus as
chosen by the lens and so that's fine
because you're simply gonna pause change
the setting of the lens and then resume
and continue of course the important
thing is you want to make sure your
white bellows your exposure and those
settings don't change in the middle of
your panorama because otherwise when you
stitch it together you get some poor
image results in often stabilizers
another question typically we recommend
leaving the stabilizer off now this one
has two modes of stabilization mode 1
and mode 2 mode 1 is for normal
vibrations and oscillations that you
might get from say wind and this is a
very heavy camera on top of a heavy
GigaPan Pro you have to have a really
strong tripod to make this whole system
work well and if you do have wind you
can of course try tuning the stabilizer
on and see if that helps with the wind
situation it's worth a shot if you're
gonna do that you probably want to
change the settings in the camera so
that you're in Live View mode so that
the stabilizer is on continuously and
warmed up and then the camera is
continuously warmed up and locked on so
that's a consideration if you're going
to leave stabilization on so those are
the issues that I wanted you to be aware
of on a lens of course the lens is so
heavy we're going to connect the GigaPan
dongle to the lens rather than the
camera and then if we go to the camera
body and just talk about some of the
settings in here and what matters will
typically shoot in manual mode we will
typically fix the white balance and so
however you like to fix the white
balance and nail it whether it's custom
setting or one of the preordained
settings is fine live
you mode again top left button is often
very useful because you're going to get
a picture where you're seeing the
sharpness of the image that you're about
to take and let's talk a little bit
about ISO sensors are so large and they
have such good signal-to-noise ratios
it's typically the case that you can go
to rather large ISO values and still get
great pictures so don't be afraid to go
to 400 and 800 because you're on this
large system on top of a tripod things
are moving you've zoomed in to 200
millimetres so the smallest vibration is
causing some blurring you really want
that shutter speed to be fast and so
it's alright to have a nice high ISO in
order to make the shutter speed as fast
as possible you don't get much noise on
these cameras until you go to really
high ISO and so that's quite alright
let's also talk about the aperture as
you sit here using this camera adjusting
the aperture one of the challenges
you'll have is should I make it release
really small aperture or wide open the
issue is typically you're concerned
about diffraction and so typically what
you're worried about is if I make the
aperture small I'm going to get into a
diffraction situation and I'm maximizing
my sharpness at some point well below
the smallest iris that's possible and
that's true so that's one reason to shy
away from the smallest aperture possible
but depth of field is a big deal and
depth of field is a real challenge with
Kay panning with a large throw lens
because you're going to be zooming in
because you can and that way you get
this fabulous resolution you can see
trees in the forest at submillimetre
resolution on the bark but when you do
that and you zoom in all the way you get
very shallow depth of field and so first
of all you've got to have autofocus on
in a situation like that or you need
things to be more or less planar or you
need to have a very small iris but if
you have a very small iris then you've
got this problem under diffraction and
suddenly the picture is softer than you
intended and you've lost some of that
that sharp focused uh detail that you're
interested in so that's the trade-off
and it's worth experimenting with that
trade-off to try and achieve the best
results possible again
middle-of-the-road is what matters often
you don't zoom in all the way of course
remember when you do that to set the
field of view again on the GigaPan Epic
Pro so that it knows how many degrees to
move per picture and often you're going
to go for something in the middle
where the ISO is larger and allows you
to have a smaller iris and still not
have a super long shutter speed that's
the key things that I want to cover in
order to give you an idea of those
general settings
now let me go through a few other
settings but before I do that on the
menu side I want to show you how to
mount the camera so mounting this camera
on top of the epic pro in involves first
attaching the connector that's designed
for the GigaPan unit and then we'll
bring in the pro and we'll simply use
the quick release to actually mount it
in typically of course I'm doing this on
top of a tripod I'm gonna do a table
right now instead just so that I have
the ability to show it to you without
need of a tripod and we can lock it if
we like so now we've got our unit on top
now to deal with the nodal point issues
what we would be doing is we would be
adjusting up down from these screws on
the sides and then we would be adjusting
this for aft for the nodal point for aft
and of course in the for app direction
for the nodal point it depends on the
zoom so as you zoom in the little points
going to move back and as you zoom out
the little prints gonna move forward in
the lens system so that's the key issues
you're going to deal with in this case
with this Canon this is the correct
cable that we use and I'm going to go
ahead and plug in the cable into the
unit just so that I can do one quick
panorama with you to give you an idea of
what it looks like when you're actually
using it so now we'll end by just doing
one very quick panorama in here and
going through all the controls setup for
that I'm going to turn the camera on
first and I've got my camera on the lens
cap is off that's good I'm going to go
ahead and adjust my my exposure and I'm
gonna have a nice open aperture in this
case until I'm happy with how things
look there we go
I'm gonna take a test picture
when you go to manual focus in this case
good so now I'm happy that I'm getting
good pictures out of the system you
can't see it but trust me now I'm going
to go ahead and turn the GigaPan Epic
Pro on and show you the process that go
on from here I've got the trigger in the
remote trigger in so I'm happy with my
pictures I'm in manual mode and go ahead
and turn on this system and once this is
on I'm gonna choose new panorama set
camera zoom and hit OK when you're done
I am done so I'm gonna go ahead and hit
OK and I'm gonna move the camera to the
upper left in this case I'm just gonna
take a silly picture of my bookcase so
here's my bookcase this means that at
home I'll be able to review all the
books on my bookcase what was a useful
thing there we go so there's a 9 by 9
picture you get pan epic shot short
panorama no let's go ahead and take the
pictures so it's gonna take 81 pictures
I'll hit OK and in gory detail I'm gonna
have the bindings of about 40 books in
very very extreme detail there's a
checklist that comes on the screen I'm
gonna go ahead and click through the
checklist it's making sure that my white
balance is locked and my exposure is
locked and my focus is locked and in
this case it is I did the focus by hand
I'm putting my hand here because I don't
want this thing to fall over since it's
on a table rather than on a tripod and
indeed it's taking pictures and it's
taking it through the remote trigger now
we're not going to wait for my pictures
to get taken so I'm going to pause it so
just to review the most important things
for you to worry about are get the nodal
point aligned appropriately especially
if you're taking pictures where you have
objects at varying distances so that
parallax is an issue make sure that as
much as possible you can deal with the
trade-off between shallow depth-of-field
and the iris size and diffraction and
vignetting so large iris you're going to
have some vignetting so you want to keep
it smaller than the largest opening for
that reason but small iris you're gonna
have diffraction and be sure to adjust
time per picture on the epic pro and the
shutter method so that you're getting
the best possible pictures you can in
the ordering that makes
all work well good luck